vous arrivez l'épisode de l'amour est
dans le pré hier c'était les sept
premiers partants regardé hier soir y
avait quoi sur m6 je ne sais pas eh bien
les portraits des agriculteurs de
l'amour est dans le pré saison 14 petit
résumé hier soir on a donc découvert cet
agriculteur au parcours de vie très
compliqué j'ai fait un essai ma mère
décédée dans gran
nearly je sais plus le public décès de
mon père un dimanche qui mangent avec
moi puis l'indus ward a été pendue et
pour apprendre à les connaître
comme d'habitude karine lemarchand leur
a posé cent cinquante mille questions
intimes de combien toi que j'aime bien
tu pars en vacances en corse ils
mesurent combien et une cuisine un peu
est-ce que tu as tracteur super puissant
une karine toujours aussi truculente 0
c'est le nombre de téléspectateurs qui
ont rigolé à cette blague
christian collin jeunes va pas y avait
quelques jours ça marche
à part ça didier a parlé mais on n'a pas
tout compris avec les arrêts avec mes
amis non comment et deux candidates ont
fait monter la température
si la peinture est agréable il faut voir
si l'autre chose ailleurs j'adore
plaisir
côté audience le retour de l'amour est
dans le pré a rassemblé trois millions
deux cent mille téléspectateurs du maire
alors d'après vous que vous cette
nouvelle saison
[Musique]
didier dans un instant alors l'amour et
non presse que vous avez dû regarder
beltra oui j'aime bien ma mère et les
fans c'est vrai bon à lembras vote
moment je connais elle s'appelle auront
soso sur les réseaux d'accord on rend
software est bien alors oui saison
plutôt décapante et surprenante deuxième
de la soirée 3 millions de méan voterait
sur un an
trois cent mille quand même je crois que
dilma commencent à fuser même si ça
reste le programme le plus petit il
s'enfuit alors je suis d'accord avec
vous le dif hommes et aux femmes plus de
femmes que l'année dernière et enfin
bien mais qui s'appelle didier la vérité
y révèle qu'il est d'accord mais on va
reparler très belle intervention
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est comprendre
comment le trouvez pas
on le comprend ainsi voudront loyer on
est en direct les 15 minutes de vérité
oui vous après deux ans de désamour j'ai
retrouvé mon émission avec de vrais gens
presse haïtienne des gueules cassées de
la vieille l'amour des gens forme il a
une karine le marchand au top je suis
content et j'ai passé un super moment de
télé pour écouter ci s'il vous avait été
content d'un côté on est content pour
vous remercier content merci oui non il
est beaucoup trop tôt pour savoir si ça
avait une bonne saison que c'est que mes
portraits ce qui énerve ans et ils sont
toujours tout beau si c'est toujours
l'émission bisounours ils ont toutes les
qualités du monde et une fac et miss on
commente on les redécouvre qui sait des
goujats ils sont son indélicat taiseux
et cetera donc écrivons écrivons mais
franchement alors la star celui qui
remporte tous les suffrages de ce
premier épisode c'est didier et bien
alors qu'on vous a préparé un top 3 et
numéro 3 de d intervention didier il a
56 ans il est éleveur de vaches à 56 ans
didier n'a jamais malheureusement planté
sa fourche dans le soir regardez ils en
parlent sans aucun problème mehdi moisi
dieppois aimait les blagues de cul comme
ça est ce que tu as une grande
expérience sexuelle aux patrons
pratiquement jamais fait non
ça m'a jamais tu appelles ça t'a jamais
manqué non pas qu il ya un lien évident
à voir une poignée prostituée puis la
wii prête à ma fait rien on va terminer
tu fasses cac et coopagri où ces
cailloux mais drogba a pour le même prix
oui c'est même un plaisir enfin en 3d
ready on aurait rigolé mais le truc mais
c'était parfait pour pourvoir
moi je suis fan s'était acteurs et que
tu fais un accent comme ça le mec est
dispo boulot vasile web the ring oui
mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut répondre à
jean michel aucontraire ce qui est
formidable cette saison c'est que les
candidats sont tout sauf parfait ils
sont parfaitement imparfait
là franchement on prend un homme qui
arrive le bâtiment pas à parler qui est
puceau on en a un autre énorme et il
arrive alors extrait bien par des
bêtises il avec son accent s'est réjoui
pas dire ça un mec qui arrive quasiment
pas parlé saint michel
bah oui c'est pour ça qu'il est
formidable c'est pour ça que les
candidats de cette saison
franchement c'est délicieux études il
importe le premier à gueuler de coupe tu
devais te dire pardon j'ai été plus gêné
devant l'émission je vous promets que
devant la villa des coeurs brisés
non je vous jure la villa des coeurs
brisés ça m'est arrivé parfois j'ai des
morceaux morceau mange un peu dépressive
c'est des moments compliqués
non mais vraiment j'ai regardé hier
qu'est ce que j'ai vu un programme de 56
ans
évidemment qu'un accent à couper au
couteau et lui demande pourquoi tu t'es
pas taper des [ __ ] il dit bassam a pas
tenté
on est dans la caricature d'actu complet
cela s'est vu sur cet agriculteur si
vous êtes partout en france vous tombez
pas que sur un puceau qu'un accent
arrêts alors à 14h à côte mais enfin on
tutoie maintenant je suis gêné dans
cette émission en numéro 2 il faut
savoir que didier aussi un problème avec
les pantalons données regarder il est
tout le temps en slip et ce sont là
entre ses travaux à karim devrait voir
que olivier fait des travaux faits très
spéciaux s'incarne est ce que c'est
c'est d'être bon là mais pourquoi tu as
laissé la porte
c'est beau verhaeghe or le voilà libre
échange et le salon a laissé cette porte
saison pour fouad alaoui non d'accord
alors abri abri abri mais je me sens un
peu d'amis d'audincourt oui il est doux
mais ma d'ici là la poudre rappel de la
décoration
derrière moi oui non ou se moquent de
toi lance des idées et gomes junior en
attendait inspiré ici
johnny c'est d'ailleurs comme johnny
alors je n'y arrivais que ce qu'il a
fait jonnhy halliday ajeli des ombres
dataflux finalement qui reçoit le canal
chez soi tout le monde fait chanter les
spectateurs qui n'a jamais planté un
course leap x de tous ceux qui disent
qu'elle est réussie sincèrement c'est à
bout de souffle c'est la quatorzième
saison et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
allés chercher des gens comme ça hyper
caricature qui vont faire le buzz et qui
vont faire en sorte que peut-être ça va
vous que ce n'est pas ce qu'on va on va
on va voir ce qu'il a dans le bide bien
la france et moi j'aime tout le gars il
est en train de faire ses travaux il en
train de publier chez lui moi je me
tourne le bol avec la cuillère moi
j'aime tout même du foot des gens non
parce que c'est des gens qui existent
mathieu parce que tu ne croise pas mais
ils existent ces gens là ils existent
pour de vrai là la maison existe pour de
vrai ya sophie de sophie l ex designers
à la fin la bcl a refait sa vie
maintenant a fait un potager avec son
père ne pouvait pas dire que ça va pas
marcher pas c'est la première houghton
un quartier j'annonce la capsule mecheri
le marché auquel tour soit il ouvre la
porte aux petites culottes sienne cas
mais là je te dis c'est une télé reste
la gueule de jean jacques un truc
l'imaginer c'est sandrine éleveuse de
chiens suis d'accord avec vous je me dis
qu est ce qu une éleveuse de chiens
vient faire là dedans sinon on fait
l'amour est partout et pas que dans près
alors alors dernière le top 20 le moment
le plus drôle c'est on arrive à mon
extrait donc je vous le dit préférer de
didier bon didier si vous avez pas un
décodeur là c'est vraiment le frère de
jean lassalle et karine vous allez voir
elle tente de comprendre mais en vain
mais on est assez fan de didier au
tournoi oui oui la flemme meilleur
teasing sava bond avec les arrêts avec
mes amis les amis des chiens à oui je
ferais doigt combien avec toi c'est pas
bon quand kurtag jodidio tanatoy
holy dis nous je parle dernier danny
danon comment 6 de boistron code of the
rings métier je ne comprends pas tout ce
que tu veux dire quoi mais je finis
niveau des doigts cette phrase par
exemple ce n'est pas comprise bâtiment à
bombardier à mannheim jeunes qui
auraient banier matin il est là il vole
oui c'est quand même hallucinant qui se
tient comme matthieu delormeau
il y met en scène en permanence sa
propre vie qui la spectacularité qui
voit quelqu'un d' authentiques il est
perdu a eu comme çà le trouble et qui ne
peut pas supporter cette personne mais
on devrait il croit c'est une honte
matthieu delormeau mais pour que depuis
des années les gens dans un miroir quand
vous vous regardez vous voyez un
mensonge là vous avez
la loi vous répondre on m'accuse je
réponds qu'il a jamais quitté bastille
et son siège sur ces news dont les
bananes donations sur la vie ou sur la
fronton petits chéris quant à vous celle
ci ne s'est pas fait au point où j'ai
perdu mon métier on atterrit t porter
sortez vous voulez me parler à moi oui
allez-y pas je m'adresse à vous ça sera
de vous à moi et naples est un des deux
qui devra quitter l'émission j'ai une
petite idée des gens parlent de mahomet
a buggé à gué ou de gay hétéro d'homme à
homme
je vous dis ceci vous qui aimez les gens
qui offrait des cadeaux qui avait le
coeur sur la main qui leur parlait sur
des réseaux et qui en permanence fait de
la télévision pour les téléspectateurs
je peux en témoigner
que vous aimiez cette émission qui se
fout ouvertement de la gueule de gens
assez simple et qui ne connaissent pas
la télévision qui ne connaissent pas les
codes
ça me choque rends toi ça vous pouvez
écouter l'émission
écoutez l'émission alors je vais vous
dire pourquoi moi je vois cette émission
elle m'a fait encore plus aimer les
agriculteurs je suis désolé et je pense
qu'elle a fait découvrir plein de choses
à plein de gens qui savaient pas comment
s'est passé le métier d'agriculteur et
déjà rien que pour ça c'est extrêmement
important
voilà donc si vous voulez m'emmerder et
bien vous allez voir ailleurs 1 ça va
être vite fait passer mais vous avez la
chance personne ne proposera d'ailleurs
parce qu'à sa partie
c'est bon mais je vous dise c'est très
beau ce que vous n'ayez donc cela veut
dire que tout ce que j'ai fait pour vous
savonner la planche a bien marché cette
semaine jeudi injuste sur qui vous a
donné la parole à prendre juste après
lui dans nos peaux dire qu'on a
tellement exclut ces personnages à la
télévision parce que tu as un accent tu
sors de la télé parce que tu handicapés
tu sors de la télé parce que tu un
strabisme tu sors de la télé et bien moi
je dis bravo d'avoir des gens différents
et ce sont des vrais gens qui s'est
passé cet hiver days tu sors de la télé
on a on a un petit extrait en bonus ce
combat - c'est l'extrait bonus de
l'amour est dans le pré regarde plutôt
ronde avec des formes plutôt finement
par contre je suis là si ses 1001 des
formes par exemple bon je parle que du
physical and any logo oui oui à 60 belle
femme du monde d'accord et pas mal de
parisiens qui voudraient qu'elle vienne
l'y invité ici un peu simple recevoir
vendredi dans balances ton post